[Musique]
Hélène buzetti Michel David Christian
Dufour bonsoir bonsoir On va revoir ces
images quand même impressionnantes au
salon rouge à Québec à l'Assemblée
nationale de monsieur Legault qui salue
ses 89 collègues députés élus on va
l'écouter ils ont disait qu'il y avait
pas de place au Québec pour un nouveau
parti à quelques années regarder ce que
ça donne on écoute on vient
au début de la cape d'arrêter de se
diviser puis de mettre toutes les
meilleures dans le même équipe
bon alors tour de table et Hélène
buzetti je le disais d'entrée de jeu il
contente l'étendue de son succès là
ah oui absolument il y a évidemment de
quoi être fier mais vous savez on
parlait de de la difficulté de faire
rentrer tout le monde dans cette
salle-là aujourd'hui et bien sa
difficulté maintenant à monsieur Legault
c'est de faire rentrer assez de monde
dans son prochain cabinet alors ça va
être le grand défi c'est de faire des
choix ça sera nécessairement difficile
et il y a fort à parier que ça va être
plus gros vous savez Patrice c'est une
constante dans toutes les capitales qu'à
mesure que les gouvernements
vieillissent leur cabinet a tendance à
grossir parce qu'on veut pas déplaire à
ceux qui ont déjà été là etc alors que
ce soit déjà un premier enjeu et déjà
Éric duem nous propose une conférence de
presse demain pour dénoncer ce qu'il
prédit à être un cabinet trop gros alors
voilà on va on va reparler du cabinet
mais quand même premier tour de table
sur ce qu'il a réussi à faire François
le gros au cours des dernières années
c'est comme si eux ils récoltait tout ce
qu'il y avait tout ce qui avait mis en
terme Michel et il y a effectivement et
d'ailleurs quand ils remerciait son ses
proches collaborateurs c'est fascinant
il y a une fédéralise qui a déjà
travaillé au fédéral et un Martin
Koskinen qui est son inséparable il y a
des il a réussi cette coalition il faut
quand même le souligner Michel
absolument c'est une réussite
remarquable mais c'est la réussite d'un
homme
à chaque fois que je vais dans un
congrès de la CAQ je suis toujours un
peu frappé par par le fait que c'est pas
un vrai parti dans le sens traditionnel
du terme c'est à dire porter par une
vision qu'on essaie de promouvoir c'est
un peu
un parti qui a rempli un vide plus qu'un
parti qui était porteur d'un projet
c'est une grande réussite mais je me
demande toujours qu'est-ce qui va
arriver quand le père fondateur va être
parti est-ce que les racines vont être
assez profondes pour continuer à faire
vivre ce partie là
sont pas encore convaincu oui est-ce que
vous dites c'est le revers de la fin si
vous dites oui grande victoire il
réussit à réunir bon des fédéralistes
des souverainistes des nationalistes des
gens mais Christian dufource que dit
Michel c'est que le prix à payer c'est
que c'est pas un parti idéologue c'est
un parti pragmatique donc il y a pas
nécessairement de grande révolution même
matin non c'est clair que c'est pas
parti révolutionnaire du tout je pense
qu'il est Québec solidaire c'est quand
même une démonstration de l'aptitude de
notre système politique à se renouveler
parce qu'on l'a oublié on a beaucoup
ridiculisé comme on le fait souvent la
CAC c'est début monsieur Legault à ses
débuts il y a eu en fait un premier
mandat exceptionnellement difficile à
cause de la covid en même temps un
premier mandat où il s'est peut-être un
peu trop habitué à être insensé être
approuvé par les médias par la classe
politique et là maintenant il y a un
deuxième mandat donc il peut être aussi
difficile on le sait déjà demandé c'est
pas toujours facile puis 90 députés
c'est un beau cadeau mais ça peut être
un cadeau à poser mais aujourd'hui un
bon moment c'est clair que c'est son
moment sur le plan humain
parce que là bien sûr après la brique
arrive
c'est normal pire entre salon rouge
c'est quand même des images
impressionnantes Véronique tout à
l'heure nous montrer la prise de photo
le photographe avait pas le cadre assez
large pour faire
ok mais là effectivement il y a des
défis Hélène dans les nouveaux là je
vous laisse le choix mais il y a des
nouveaux qui ont des dents longues qui
veulent être ministre qui seront
ministre face à Bernard drin ville bien
sûr on a souligné l'arrivée de
cateri-champagne Jourdain la femme
autochtone donc il y a beaucoup de gens
qui lèvent la main qui s'attendent avoir
un appel au cours des prochaines heures
oui évidemment on fera pas le tour de
toutes les personnages dont on a qu'on a
mentionné jusqu'à présent j'en ajouterai
seulement un une en fait Suzanne
Tremblay en fait qui m'a député ici à
old
elle est quand même réussi l'exploit de
mettre fin à un règne libéral de 40 ans
dans cette circonscription si ça a très
peu été mentionné depuis l'élection
c'est quand même une petite révolution
ici en Outaouais c'est une ancienne
syndicaliste dans le milieu de
l'éducation l'enseignante peut-être que
le milieu de l'éducation pourrait être
un appel pour eux pour elle et dans la
région il faut quand même pas oublier
que l'outaway avec 400 000 habitants à
peu près là seulement un ministre il y a
d'autres régions je pense notamment à la
Mauricie qui en ont beaucoup plus que ça
je ne sais pas si elle est dans les
plans mais c'est intéressant surtout que
beaucoup d'enjeux notamment sur la santé
et l'éducation cette école secondaire le
détruite par la tornade de 2018 qui est
toujours pas reconstruite il y a quand
même des gros enjeux ici en Outaouais
deux ministres c'est peut-être pas trop
ok Michel David vous disiez là le
plaisir commence là et il va falloir
faire des choix quelques déçu d'ailleurs
il a dit aux députés vous avez le droit
à discuter dans le caucus mais quand on
sort il faut qu'on soit uni à lancer un
message on a parlé tout à l'heure mais
son plus grand défi au cours des
prochaines semaines Michel David
j'ai l'impression que monsieur Legault
fera pas un si gros ménage que ça dans
son dans son conseil des ministres il y
a quand même une marge de manœuvre il
est à 26 députés sauf erreur au moment
de la dissolution il peut facilement se
rendre à une trentaine sans concret au
scandale et il y a et là c'est surtout
intéressant pour les femmes qui aspirent
à devenir ministre les trois ministres
du Conseil des cabinet précédent qui ne
se sont pas représentés à toutes des
femmes et
Nathalie Roy c'est un peu exclu de la
course elle-même en disant bon mais moi
j'aime autant être
enfin à le prévenu les coups disons en
disant qu'elle avait préféré être à
l'Assemblée nationale alors il y a au
moins quatre postes qui vont se libérer
qui étaient occupés par des femmes et
qui devraient très certainement l'être
encore alors
je pense que monsieur Legault peut se
permettre d'attirer du sang neuf sans
sans comment dire multiplier les
frustrations il y en aura mais c'est
tout à fait gérable je pense il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui peuvent accéder
bon Martin Biron Suzanne Roy qui a été
riche en tant que Jourdain on a parlé
français le grand public la connaît pas
mais il y en a plusieurs c'est l'une est
taillant
et il prend pas tout accéder au Conseil
des ministres mais il y en a plusieurs
qui non seulement mériteraient de l'être
mais que monsieur Legault aurait
avantage je pense à mettre à mettre en
valeur parce que faut pendant plusieurs
mois et ça revenait souvent
souvenez-vous dans la bouche des des
oppositions le Boys Club et ça monsieur
Legault je pense qu'il veut arrêter de
projeter cette image là et peut-être
même majoritairement féminin comme on a
parlé tout à l'heure pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas je pensais à ça
que la taxe c'est beaucoup François
Legault ce qui est vrai c'est quand même
le fondateur mais en même temps on
connaît beaucoup les ministres on peut
pas dire que c'est un gouvernement dont
on connaît juste monsieur Lego c'est pas
mal le même monde qui reconduit les
femmes c'est plus un problème moi je
trouve que au Québec le sud de nos
fiertés d'ailleurs ça a été souligné
dans un article après ces deux trois
jours il faut on peut être fier là il y
a une grande représentation des
minorités visibles des autochtones des
femmes bon ça ça va de soi c'est moins
c'est qu'est-ce qui va faire avec ce
super majorité avec son super
gouvernement bon je disais comme tout le
monde c'est priorité le sur papier là
mais c'est pas si clair que ça
définitivement
la scène bon jusqu'à quel point
l'opposition va être capable
d'influencer ça c'est un grand moment
mais ils sont là pour faire quoi au
juste mais voilà c'est la question que
je posais tout à l'heure et comme Michel
vous disiez oui qu'on va dans un congrès
il y a pas de grands c'est ça l'idée il
y a des choses à gérer la santé on l'a
vu les urgences ça recommence de plus
belle on vient de voir Monsieur Dubé il
l'aura pas facile non plus le monsieur
Dubé d'un prochain mois là
aucun des ministres de la santé depuis
un quart de siècle et il y a rien qui
assure que Monsieur Duguet Dubé va
gagner son Paris là je pense qu'ils vont
ils vont être trois à de presque
monsieur Legault a laissé entendre à la
santé donc clairement on va marquer là
que c'est une priorité mais vous savez
la dernière fois la priorité c'était
l'éducation et je pense que Monsieur
Robert va être muté et ça va envoyer le
message que finalement il y aura raté
son coup alors c'est pas parce qu'on a
une priorité que
j'ajouterais peut-être aussi c'est la
relation avec Ottawa ici
c'est important de garder un contact
avec le gouvernement fédéral surtout que
quand même certaines certains
affrontements ce profil
attention voilà bon évidemment celui du
financement de la santé mais les
demandes en immigration les questions
sur la laïcité etc qui sont devant les
tribunaux qui vont recommencer à Ottawa
on dit qu'on a certains ministres avec
qui on a de très bonnes relations en
premier lieu Sonia Lebel et on dit que
ça nous ferait beaucoup de peine qu'elle
ne soit plus
l'intermédiaire ou l'interlocutrice
principale du gouvernement logo une
chose que l'on craint ici à Ottawa c'est
que Simon Janin Barrett revient par
exemple à l'immigration en tout cas de
redevienne dans un rôle qui l'amènerait
beaucoup à parler avec
Ottawa on semble ne pas avoir d'atomes
crochus du tout avec le ministre
pas c'est comme leur premier mandat en
fait parce que la covid a tellement été
énorme et tellement longue ça leur
confisqué leur premier mandat donc ça
leur éviter de prendre possession sur un
tas de sujet bon et là on a raison les
relations avec Ottawa c'est fondamental
juste dans le dossier d'immigration le
vue hier Patricia avec l'entrevue que
vous avez faites-le avec le ministre
c'est pas très bon les relations
Ottawa qui avait commencé l'immigration
et moi la question que je me pose quand
même là bon moi je pense au gouvernement
il y a le goût que j'aime bien mais je
demande si au fil d'arriver là bah ce
grand mouvement conservateur qui nous
rassure bon on va être l'audace je n'ai
pas danger qu'on sombre comme société
dans une certaine médiocrité en fait
tranquille le poste scandaleuse mais je
vois pas beaucoup d'audace ou de projets
qui nous stimulerait beaucoup c'est
c'est un peu des questions qu'on peut se
poser en fait face à ce super parti qui
a pris totalement le contrôle de du
gouvernement de façon démocratique vous
venez dire quelque chose d'extrêmement
important toujours vous allez me dire
quand vous dites non mais vous le disiez
en passant comme c'était quand vous
dites les il est on lui a confisqué son
premier mandat combien de gens nous ont
écrit depuis qu'on couvre cette élection
depuis plusieurs semaines en disant dans
le fond il y a pas pu terminer son
premier mandat monsieur Legault alors il
y a on doit lui en donner cette victoire
très importante c'est beaucoup ça c'est
pas tellement ils ont été parfaits puis
ils ont tel projet mais ils peuvent tout
finir ce qu'on commençait on a beaucoup
entendu ça Michel je pense qu'il y a
quand même récolter beaucoup de crédit
pour sa gestion de la pandémie au total
malgré les bavures là il y en a eu mais
les gens étaient satisfaits et oui
monsieur Lego pendant 2 ans a été obligé
de se concentrer presque exclusivement
sur la crise sanitaire et là on va voir
et et j'ai hâte de voir par exemple
quand on parle du super ministère
économique qu'on confirait à Pierrefitte
Gabin je pense que monsieur Legault le
malgré toutes les priorités qui nous
sortent là c'est rendu de la transition
énergétique sont Dada ça demeure
l'économie et je pense que évidemment
c'est une référence avec une récession
ça va ils sont tous là mais son mandat
je pense qu'il sera peut-être son
dernier je pense qu'il voudrait qu'il
soit d'abord économique sans son
obsession de la création de la richesse
puis rattraper l'Ontario c'est c'est ça
du bluff je suis convaincu que c'est
vraiment ce qui habite au premier chef
monsieur Legault et fils Gabin et sophie
Brochu qui regarde
négociations
je veux parler des libéraux parce que
c'est pourquoi on parle de la CAF et des
libéraux Madame et Monsieur il y a pas
de complot parce que aujourd'hui la
sermentation de la CAC et des libéraux
demain ça sera Québec solidaire on parle
Québec solidaire il participe québécois
mais on va dire un mot sur le serment
tout à l'heure mais bon on va écouter
madame anglaise qui dit oui il faut
quand même être lucide on écoute
nous sommes également entièrement
lucides quand au résultat de l'élection
du 3 octobre dernier notre députation
provient de la grande région
métropolitaine le Parti libéral de
Québec doit redevenir le carrefour entre
les grandes idées d'aujourd'hui et de
demain et les Québécois de toutes les
régions nous avons donc un énorme
travail à accomplir et nous en sommes
conscients
alors tour de table sur la situation
actuelle pour Madame les troupes de
libérales
dit qu'elle est lucide mais je pense
qu'elle ne l'est pas encore tout à fait
assez
il y a toutes les chiffres camoufles
donne une importance démesuré à sa
députation tous les chiffres camouflent
donc son effondrement auprès de
l'électorat francophone et les libéraux
sont totalement écartelés déchirés par
la situation de votons oui ou non
reconnaître les deux autres parties le
Parti québécois et Québec solidaire et
ça ça repose beaucoup sur les épaules de
Madame Anglade d'un côté on la comprend
stratégiquement tactiquement parlant
donner un statut officiel aux deux
autres partis en particulier Québec
solidaire
de risquer de perdre un peu le monopole
de l'opposition alors si c'est de donner
le train Hélène je m'excuse je vous
presse je vous presser de ne pas aller
vers tendre la main aux deux parties
représentées
ne pas le faire c'est de paraître
vraiment masqué mais en même temps on
comprend sa position dire ben c'est
toujours ça nous de faire des ressources
pourquoi c'est pas le gouvernement qui
porte des ressources pour accommoder ces
deux autres
écarteler donc oui mais c'est parce
qu'il y en a les fans dans la pièce là
aujourd'hui que dans André Fortin il
voulait surtout pas entendre parler
c'est le lit de Chypre de Madame de
Madame Anglade quand on dit qu'il faut
redéfinir le parti puisqu'il faut
reconnecter ça passe d'abord par le chef
dans notre système politique on
s'identifie énormément au chef d'un
parti et tant que Madame Anglade tant
que ce problème là serait pas réglé au
sein du Parti libéral
ne pourra pas suivre
alors ça je pense et pour ce qui est du
négociations avec les autres parties je
comprends madame anglais vous savez
quand on a peu de pouvoir on a encore
moins envie de le partager et Madame
anglais dans l'esprit de beaucoup elle
est un peu une usure pastriste dans le
sens que l'opposition officielle très
bien on la trouve pas dans dans le parti
libérale Christian je pense que c'est
les glucides elle sait qu'il y en a un
gros gros problème moi je suis moins sûr
que Michel que le problème tienne avant
toi ça sa personnalité je pense que il
est dans une situation quoi qu'elle
fasse elle va perdre bon au fond la
réalité le drame pour eux c'est que le
Parti libéral si on caricature c'est
devenu le parti des anglais puis en même
temps c'est la position officielle donc
l'opposition officiel par définition ça
leur présenter tout le Québec puis en
plus de ça comme le dit Hélène
reconnaitre les deux autres parties
c'est pas facile du bien parce que ce
qu'elle a elle fait l'opposition
officielle donc moi je comprends
qu'apprenne son temps pour y penser
comme il faut en définitif parce qu'elle
peut pas gagner grand chose on va voir
rapidement des extraits sur le serment
on faut pas se laisser parler du serment
au roi on écoute on revient c'est pas
long
est-ce que c'est un système qui mérite
d'être revu certainement parce que des
éléments qui sont dépassés mais il faut
respecter les lois puis j'invite les
gens qui veulent changer les lois à
venir sierger à l'Assemblée nationale
pour faire les changements qui veulent
faire
changer
nationale
ça ne fait pas plus plaisir que personne
ne prêter serment à Charles III mais
c'est prévu par la Constitution
actuellement mais nous de notre côté on
est ouvert à faire adopter un projet de
loi justement pour faire pour mettre fin
au serment d'allégeance à la royauté à
monarchie britannique d'ailleurs dans
réforme parlementaire que le
gouvernement déposé en février 2020 donc
j'avais déposé on prévoyait déjà qu'on
souhaitait abolir le serment
bon ben qui rentre ils vont avoir eu
gain de cause Michel David c'est un peu
le message qu'on leur envoie au pékist
ouais mais monsieur je pense que
Monsieur saint-pierre-la-mondon peut pas
dire bon mais je vois le prêter quand
même le servant je pense que c'est
peinturé dans le coin et je pense que
au simple plan de la stratégie c'est
excellent on a pas parlé autant des
autres parties que du PQ depuis
l'élection en bonne partie à cause de ça
et je pense le projet de loi
puis écouter ça empêchera pas monsieur
saint-pierre-la-mondon de je pense qu'on
va l'autoriser à donner des conférences
de presse au Parlement alors ça je pense
qu'il y a pas d'inconvénients il peut
pas il rentre du trop loin Hélène vous
êtes d'accord je suis du même avis puis
en fait pour jusqu'à maintenant de toute
façon le Parti québécois ce serait trois
indépendants donc avec des pouvoirs très
limités si le siège est je pense que
beaucoup plus à gagner de tenir son goût
d'avoir la cohérent de rester dans la
dans les gradins des visiteurs et ça me
mettra évidemment la pression sur
intéressant bon on est reparti on est
reparti c'est très bien merci pourquoi à
vous trois on suit ça demain Québec
solidaire en effet jeudi je vous le
souligne c'est à 13h émission spéciale
qui sera nommé ministre merci Hélène
Michel Christian la prochaine au revoir
bonne soirée au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI